this video is sponsored by Squarespace
hey there guys today I'm going to try
something a bit different I'm going to
break down for you my top 10 favorite
exercises these are 10 that I personally
use that I've used with others the ones
I enjoy ones that get results and ones
that I think together can operate almost
comprehensive program for building
functional training and performance I've
seen other creators do this so I thought
I'd throw my hat into the ring but
before I begin I should offer some
ground rules because you see in order to
choose the best 10 exercises you have to
ask yourself the best for what so as
always I'm of course looking at
functional performance I'm looking at
exercises that are going to help you to
move more healthfully and in a pain-free
manner going to improve your athleticism
and develop a well-rounded physique with
no obvious flaws or gaps in it so that's
what we're looking at today and anything
extra like hypertrophy or max strength
gains Etc these are just added nice
bonuses that might give these exercises
a few added points When selecting
exercises I try to look at things that I
use personally things that I enjoy using
are actually fun but also things that
offer a lot of benefits and that are
things that are practical so there's a
kind of Venn diagram and I'm looking for
overlap here so for example I love the
medal slam and that could have been
Incorporated here but in reality it's
not quite as useful as something like
the kettlebell swing because it doesn't
offer you quite as many benefits at the
same time I also do far fewer Med ball
slams simply because it's tricky to do
because you need to have a med ball you
need space where you can slam it on the
ground without further Ado let's get
going and my number one first choice for
top exercise is push-ups now this nearly
didn't make the list because it has some
Crossover with dips which we'll get to
in a moment because I also really like
crawls if we're looking for a push
exercise but if I'm being honest with
myself push-ups are still one of the
real bread and butter exercises that I
use for my training shops helped me
build my physique there's something that
nearly anyone can do at least easy
progressions if you do a wall push-up or
knees on the floor and they're practical
and you can do them literally anywhere
as you guys know I've talked at length
about how I perform push-ups in the kind
of bouncing manner with a short range of
motion a lot of the time this is great
as a form of conditioning it builds
strength endurance at the same time it
floods the muscles with blood and
metabolite which stimulates growth
hypertrophy but also encourages things
like recovery nutrient delivery oxygen
delivery Etc I really recommend this or
you can go much slower and use a more
controlled full range of motion and I
like to combine these two to get all the
benefits and when you do high high
repetitions or really slow controlled
push-ups this can make them difficult
enough to do even at higher levels and
then you've got all of the variations
things like explosive clapping push-ups
which are really cool things like
one-handed push-ups which you know it's
a bit of a cheat to throw them in here
but they're great for all kinds of
things such as anti-rotation so yeah the
push-up it's one of the fundamentals of
training for a reason I really love the
push-up thing everyone should do
push-ups in some way shape or form and
that's why the number one on this list
oh and this list isn't in any particular
order so pay no heed to which is first
which is last
in a similar vein number two for me is
pull-ups I think pull ups are likewise
fantastic whereas push-ups are your
pushing movement pull-ups are a basic
pulling movement of course pull-ups are
fantastic because they build the lats
the grip the biceps you can switch the
grip and do chin UPS or neutral grip
pull-ups which is great if you want to
Target the biceps more the lats more you
can do arched pull-ups if you want to
really retract the scapular and build it
that way and also it's just fun if I
walk into a gym and I see a pull-up bar
I just instantly gravitate towards it I
want to jump up there grab it and do
pull-ups so yeah I love pull-ups in all
their shapes and forms and I think again
this is a real staple that everybody
should be doing I would say that rock
climbing is even better than pull-ups
because it challenges your lats and your
grip and your biceps in much the same
way all your pulling muscles but it does
so in a more Dynamic and realistic and
functional manner but of course the
reason rock climbing isn't on this list
is because most people don't have access
to a rock climbing wall at least not
conveniently and so pull-ups are a more
realistic thing to make a staple a
regular part of your training if you
find it odd that I mentioned rock
climbing as an alternative substitute
for pull-ups that's because I think
sometimes these Dynamic activities can
serve as exercises particularly if you
perform the hobby or the activity in a
manner designed to stimulate the muscles
so you can perform rock climbing but not
in the way as to make it a hobby or to
get to the top but in a way that focuses
on building Latin bicep strength I talk
about this at length in my book adaptive
training next up on my list is body
weight Rose so bodyweight rows do have
some overlap with pull-ups especially if
you're doing arched back pull-ups
essentially this is a horizontal row
instead of a vertical row you're pulling
your body towards the bar but you're
doing it whilst lying down pulling your
sternum to meet the bar instead now
arched pull-ups are really difficult and
you're going to fail for a whole host of
reasons whereas body weight Rose really
focus on that motion so I don't think
it's important to train at different
trajectories and having a horizontal Row
in there is important generally but I
really like these in particular because
they let you focus on retracting the
scapula this will give you greater range
of motion greater shoulder stability it
can transfer to skills and the really
great thing about body weight Rose is
that they don't create a lot of muscle
damage they're not very neurologically
taxing meaning that you can actually
train them quite a lot and just throw
them in to a workout and the benefits
you get from them are just massive you
can also adapt them to be slightly more
focused on the rear delts which are
drastically overlooked and by keeping
the Torso rigid you have this great
anti-flexion movement there as well
which is a perfect antidote to sitting
so in some ways you're getting some of
the same benefits if you perform this
correctly as you would do from something
like the reverse plank which is why I've
opted to put this here and not that next
up are dips so dips are basically
push-ups but harder it's a vertical push
instead of a horizontal push and they
give you the opportunity to load extra
weight on as well if I want to get a
chest pump if I want to get a great
chest workout the way I do that is with
dips and at the same time it's a great
way to train the shoulders and the
triceps it's really simple movement once
again it's fun because you're Defying
Gravity going up and down I really like
it you can either pump out these big
sets I do sets of 30 or throw on a
weight belt maybe with 20 kilograms and
do some that way it's a really easy
great convenient way to get a great push
workout in and at the same time I once
again love all the different variations
I really like one that I saw on Sunday
Berg's Channel recently where he was
doing straight armed dips not letting
his chest touch the bar very cool for
building straight arm strength I also
like tuck planche dips as well great way
to build straight arm strength and train
towards the planche in general having a
pair of dip bars at home or in the
office is a really cost effective space
effective tool that can give you lots
and lots of training options these are
also great for performing the
aforementioned bodyweight Rose so if
you're looking for something you can
purchase that's going to give you lots
of options then dip bars I think are one
of the very best investments you can
make
next up is another pushing movement and
that's handstands this is a vertical
pushing movement this is a vertical
pushing movement up instead of down you
might be thinking handstands aren't an
exercise they're a skill and that's true
but I think we should have some skills
in our training diet as well as just
exercises designed to tax the muscles
handstands are a journey in order to
learn to handstand you need to improve
your shoulder Mobility your core
strength and stability your
proprioception your balance and this
journey will take you places in terms of
your Fitness and help you to fix little
imbalances and to focus on aspects of
your Fitness that you might not have
thought about involves shoulder
elevation like a shrug so you're
building traps as well you need to
squeeze the glutes to keep the legs
straight and like I say just be aware of
the whole body there's great mental
training as well and talk about fun hand
balancing is one of the most fun and
rewarding things you can do now a lot of
people aren't going to immediately be
able to do handstands and so they might
be you know reluctant to add this to
their training but there's lots of easy
progressions you can do whether it's
something like a crow stand whether it's
a pike push-up whether it's wall
assisted handstand push-ups this is a
journey that's worth taking and the
point is not to get to the hands down
but just to focus on the training as you
lead yourself there it's the journey on
destination that said once you manage
your handstand you can do things like
handstand push-ups your body becomes a
gym you can use literally anywhere and
yeah I think we should have more stuff
like this in our training more stuff
that isn't just sets and Reps of an
exercise but rather as a skill rather as
a a whole field to explore that's going
to expand our movement vocabulary next
up it's time we gave the legs some love
and for that I'm going to be talking
about squats so squats are a
fantastic exercise if you want to train
the quads and strengthen the knees at
the same time squats are a
difficult exercise to involve pushing
your knees forwards leaning backwards
and thereby making a regular squat much
more difficult but if you're looking for
a body weight exercise that you can do
with no weight no equipment that's going
to properly train the legs you know it's
an actual challenge then I think this is
the one to do I love doing City squats
they also look really cool just like
some of these other exercises they have
a visual appeal and for those who can't
do a city squat right away I recommend
instead trying something like the Hindu
squat the Hindi squat is a very similar
concept but instead of Leaning your
weight forwards you're just going down
on the balls of your feet made a whole
video about it also has this really cool
breathing system that makes it possible
to use this as a form of conditioning
there's a great way to strengthen the
knee strengthen the quads at home for
high rep ranges really love both these
exercises and again it shows that you
can get a good leg workout with
calisthenics speaking of the next one is
Cossack squats so Cossack squats are a
form of squat we're going to go down on
one leg and you're gonna extend the
other leg out to the side this involves
a lot of Mobility because you need that
hip abduction you need a bit of external
rotation at the same time it's placing
the weight more on one leg making it
almost a form of single leg training at
the same time we need to maintain good
posture you need to have your heel flat
on the floor all these things together
make this a fantastic form of training
you're getting Mobility you're training
in the frontal plane which is so
overlooked great for cutting changing
direction Etc so yeah the Cossack
squat's fantastic and I like it I've
been doing it for a long long time
because it's what every anime hero does
when they warm up before a fight whether
it's Goku or even Sonic the Hedgehog
before you play a level so yeah the
Cossack squat is cool I will say it's a
bit of anomaly on this list because it's
the one I actually enjoy the feeling of
doing the least like I'm like oh Cossack
squats is there anything on there like
that but it's because they feel a bit
uncomfortable but that's a good thing
because it means I know I'm getting some
benefit from it I like to perform
crosstalk squats with a kettlebell held
not only does this let me get deeper
into the squat and compensate for some
of my Mobility limitations acting as a
counterbalance it also of course means a
greater challenge for the supporting leg
meaning I can build some serious leg
strength like this as well but what you
will need to care about for is the
kettlebell swing kettlebell swings are a
brilliant exercise they do take some
time to learn because you need to do
that hip hinge properly so if you're not
used to dead lifting or you haven't done
kettlebell swings to begin with you
might find you're squatting too much or
rounding the back you can hurt yourself
with this so you need to ease yourself
in gently and start with a lighter
weight and I recommend watching my
kettlebell swings video and a whole
bunch of other videos out there on
kettlebell swings but once you get this
right then not only are you training
that hip hinge and really cementing that
movement pattern by performing high high
repetitions of it also training the
glutes making them stronger and you're
doing a kind of extension here with the
knees and the hips at the same time
which translates to Greater jump height
running speed and the great thing about
kettlebell swings as well is that you
can use them as a form of conditioning
metabolic conditioning you can use
really long rep ranges that you're
building strength but at the same time
strength endurance getting in a bit of
cardio fat loss in a way that's fun and
challenging and because the weight is
offset it's swinging all these different
ways and you've got the momentum to
tackle with so every repetition is
slightly different then there's all the
variations you can do you can do the
sport swing the hard style swing you can
switch into some kind of snatch or drop
back on one leg so many cool options the
kettlebell swing again is a whole world
of different exercises and all of them
are brilliant for building glute
strength and work capacity two things
that belong in any workout and something
like this shows that if you're not into
cardio you don't have to go for long
long runs doing long sets of kettlebell
swings at home in the comfort of your
own home at the end of a workout is a
brilliant way to get many of the same
benefits next up is one that you won't
likely hear on a lot of lists that's the
crossbody kettlebell swing you're going
to be swinging the Kettlebell across the
body rotating at the waist and rotating
at the hip at the same time this is
brilliant because it trains transverse
strength rotational strength I talk
about this all the time on the channel
how we don't rotate the body enough and
when you think about it most sports
activities most things you do in life
involve rotation whether it's wrestling
whether it's running whether it's
throwing all these things require you to
twist your body interestingly I think
that a lot of people's favorite
exercises and the things we do the most
in the gym revolve around pushing but
name me Sports involve pushing versus
ones that involve pulling or rotating
and you'll find that there's a lot more
pulling and rotating and most people do
nothing for rotation not only will this
translate to Greater all-round
functional performance in every sport
and activity it's even good for
Aesthetics because you'll develop nicer
bleaks which give you much more detail
down the midsection it's one secret to
looking much more ripped without
dropping body fat there are lots of
options for rotational strength you can
do things like you know band punch-outs
or you can do anti-rotation with things
like the aforementioned one arm push-up
but the crossbody kettlebell swing is
one I find really fun and I also really
feel it working and because you're
rotating the core and the hips you get
double bang for your buck it's just
another excellent exercise this one
though I do recommend you proceed with
caution start light don't do too many to
begin with because if you're out of
practice it's a great way to pull a
muscle or something so ease into it but
then this is a great one to use as well
also another one that just looks badass
as you swing this weight across in front
of your face like a lunatic of course
you need to include some core training
here and for that I'm going to be
picking the hollow body hold the hollow
body is a exercise from gymnastics it's
also used in a whole host of other types
of training such as calisthenics
basically you're going to be turning
your body into a kind of dish lie on the
floors to do this and create a posterior
pelvic tilt so that the lower back is
pushing into the ground and contract the
ABS the rectus abdominis so that your
body slightly crunches forwards you're
not bending forwards you're just lifting
your shoulders and neck off the ground
keep your arms straight your legs
straight in front of you this is
training the core to build stability
you'll feed it really quickly and it's a
great basis for a bunch of other
exercises like the front lever the
dragon flag a whole lot of other stuff
and it translates to Greater athletic
performance in every Pursuit because as
Stuart McGill would say proximal
stiffness creates distal athleticism you
need that stability that strengthened
the core to be able to properly
translate Force into the limbs so this
will improve you in every area like that
at the same time it's training that
transverse abdomini giving you more
support and stability in the spine and
sucking in the ABS to give you a nice
flat aesthetic look in the gut and
finally the last exercise that I highly
recommend everyone do is running and I
will accept walking as an alternative
running is not only a great way to burn
calories it's something that we are
designed to do and it trains good
biomechanics it gets blood flowing
around the body it can be used as a form
of active recovery I personally
recommend running at a slower Pace you
don't have to go fast and try and beat
your times all the time and focus on
just getting blood around your body
reinforcing good movement patterns Etc
building hip stability and for extra
credit trail running is even better
because you have to be more comfortably
engaged and you need to stabilize your
body more like doing it in my barefoot
shoes running is just one of the best
ways to burn tons of calories improve
your cardio Fitness run more you'll feel
more energetic you'll improve your
biomechanics like some other options on
this list running isn't just an exercise
it's like a whole activity unto itself
there's so much to explore here so many
areas that you can improve if there's
anything we take from this list I think
that's what you should be looking for
things that are Dynamic things that are
expandable with more to learn and more
to experiment with what do you think
guys do you agree with my list you
disagree what would you include or
exclude like I said I'm still upset I've
had to leave some things out I'd love to
hear your lists in the comments down
below so share them there and if you
want a training program that
incorporates all this kind of stuff for
a more Dynamic and all-round performance
from ability strength endurance even
focus and decision making then check out
my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 the protein
performance system is on summer sale
right now but won't be for much longer
so so yeah check out the link down below
if you're interested by the way thank
you so much for watching this one guys
and I'll see you next time
bye for now
now I just like to take a moment to talk
about today's sponsor Squarespace
Squarespace is a platform for building
websites that makes it extremely simple
and easy to get started but also has all
of the advanced features you could need
in order to expand your website and your
business as far as you want to go when I
say it's easy to start a website with
Squarespace I really mean it you can
choose a pre-made template and then edit
it as much as you like using their
fantastic fluid engine that lets you
just simply drag and drop elements into
place to change the design how you want
you don't need to know coding you don't
need to spend hours tweaking things that
don't work you just have a vision
implement it and you have a beautiful
modern and adaptive website ready to go
you really can have a website up and
running in minutes that can then support
your business your hobbies they can then
access their portfolio you know there's
tons of reasons to make a website and
with Squarespace there's just no barrier
to entry but like I said they also have
all the advanced tools you could want
with this Advanced publishing and
formatting tools whether it's building a
community online with threaded comments
replies and likes
with its analytics e-commerce gated
members only content as another form of
Revenue generation it can expand this
even further with plugins from the
community that add even more options
whether that's things like global
Shipping for your e-commerce Inventory
management tax reconciliation the sky's
really the limit it Powers some of the
biggest brands on the web so yes I
highly recommend giving Squarespace a go
if you're interested in starting a
website if you want to find out more
then go to squarespace.com when you're
ready to launch buy any of your viewers
can get 10 off their first website or
domain by going to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer Link in the
description down below thank you once
again to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video thanks to you guys for watching
and bye for now